you are juggling a lot this season the
tournament terry silver anthony having a
bigger role mandatory i can go on and on
what is your process for getting a sense
of
if it's the right balance and how many
key story threads to include because i
was very impressed by how much is in
season four and how it all makes sense
you know it's it's always a challenge in
the writer's room this was a unique
season because we have johnny and daniel
together in in a story uh for the first
time and they're sharing a lot of screen
time so it freed up some room for other
characters to
to uh spread their wings a little bit
but the all valley tournament that was
baked in terry silver we knew that we
wanted to bring him back this season and
have him uh you know team up with with
crease and be a uh
a rival to the johnny and daniel to team
up and anthony's been there hiding in
plain sight this whole time he's uh
a character that we've always loved he's
usually been a good source of punchlines
but we figured it was time for him to
have his own karate kid journey and uh
it's uh it's always a challenge finding
the right balance but uh season four was
uh was a really fun one
you know it's so funny we we had so much
story in season four like john said
because johnny and daniel are sharing
space you know they they naturally
become the a story together and we knew
we were introducing new characters you
know such as kenny and devin and we knew
we were going to do interesting things
you know when it comes to what the
tournament is and how that's going to
evolve and we wanted to lay everything
in you know as as easily and as with
enough flow as possible without the
episodes just ballooning to a point of
feeling cumbersome but um you know we
hit that sweet spot as you're as you're
putting cards on the wall you're
shifting things around you're saying can
we do this in three episodes as opposed
to cramming it all into one and it
becomes like a ballet it becomes an
orchestra you're feeling you know you
need more strings in one episode and you
need more woodwinds in the next and uh
you know we're really proud of how much
story we've been able to tell in season
four
so i know that you've said it kind of
came down to the wire with elizabeth's
true uh lassies and then it made me
wonder have you always known that thomas
would 100 get involved in season four or
was there ever a you know a backup plan
in case terry silver wasn't a big role
this time around
anytime that we approach a cast member
from one of the original movies we are
very optimistic and very hopeful and you
know very confident in our abilities to
sell what we're going to be doing with
their character
and you know especially with thomasy and
griffith i mean we we knew that uh we
had a lot of fun stuff planned for terry
silver so you know you never know
obviously you know they have to say yes
um but we've been lucky that you know
whenever we talk to these actors they
usually respond really well to you know
what we're pitching and you know also
for most actors who've been in those
movies like they really love the crowded
kid it was a huge part of their career
so it's it's a thrill it's it's like a
high school reunion for them to to come
back into this world and they've now
seen what we've done with cobra kai so
you know i we're we're pretty confident
we could get uh almost any character
from the movies at this point i believe
in you guys i also believe you can get
someone else if you really wanted
because seeing andrew garfield's
reaction to the show delighted me to no
end so i'm going to put you on the spot
creatively let's say he wanted to join
the show i guess for season six at this
point what kind of character would you
cast him as and which dojo would he join
i don't even know how to answer that
right now i will say that we were we
were giddy as well when we saw his
reaction and how much he loves the show
we're we're all fans of his he's such an
amazing
talented actor
that you'd want to find something that
is surprising i think that you'd want
you to give him a unique look and a
unique feel and a unique angle and make
him
unlike any other character in the show i
think that's where we'd start but as to
any specifics i i probably shouldn't say
anything because who knows maybe he will
be on the show and i don't want to take
any chances of
ruining that i know in in the video
andrew garfield had mentioned miyagido
forever so i have a feeling that he's
going to gravitate towards uh
daniel larussa i feel like he's a tech
billionaire who buys out all the auto
you know uh sales places in the valley
and becomes just the ultimate foil for
everybody you spoiled spoiled it
everything you can't do it now
suggests it should such different things
but it speaks to his versatility as an
actor and i could see him in all those
roles
exactly
thank you guys for your time today and
yet again congratulations oh thank you
talk to you soon
you